Bill cosby as a standup
comedian and accent,
they became an American icon and someone
who millions of people look to as a
father figure and as a moral compass,
he would disappoint the entire world.
When they began to learn this,
he was not at all the wonderful person
that he portrayed himself to be detailed
biographics we're going to talk about
the life, the Korea and the downfall.
Bill Cosby.
Okay.
What do you make calls to be?
Junior was born in Philadelphia in
1937 and he was one of four children.
His mother and a Pearl
was a maid and his father,
William Henry Cosby senior was
that steward in the u s navy.
He was always the class clown and never
took his education very seriously.
He had failed so many classes that he
decided to drop out of high school in the
10th grade in order to follow in his
father's footsteps and join the navy.
He eventually earned a GED
through a military program.
He went to Temple University
in Philadelphia, runs, uh,
an athletic scholarship to be on that
track and field team while in college.
She works part time as a bartender and
would enjoy entertaining as customers by
telling jokes and making witty comments.
His customers encouraged him to get into
stand up comedy so we began going to
east coast comedy clubs in Philadelphia,
in New York City.
People enjoy it as comedy is so much that
he was able to book tours to the major
cities around the country.
He dropped out of college when he was 20
years old in favor of trying to make a
career and stands up.
He appeared in several TV series telling
us jokes and including the tonight show
in 1964 he married a
woman named Camille Hanks.
She was only 20 years old and in her
sophomore year of college at the time and
bill calls and he was 27 they met on a
blind date and didn't know each other
that well before they got married.
They went on to have five
children together during
his stand up routines cause
it'd be, would talk a lot about his kids
and how difficult it was being a father.
Most parents could relate to everything
he was saying and it was considered to
be clean,
wholesome comedy.
In 1965 bill Cosby it at a starring
role on the TV show I spike.
He became the first African American
to star in a network television show.
He was an inspiration to people everywhere
in the young black men particularly
looked up to him as a role model.
However,
Isi was seen almost as a one hit wonder
and Cosby was not given any more of
these dashing roles in the future since
he was so popular with parents and he
had experience raising kids of his own,
he turns one of his standup characters.
Fat Albert's into a cartoon series
geared towards young urban kids,
often making some money from his career.
He wins on to finish his bachelor's and
eventually receive a master's degree and
a phd in education from the
University of Massachusetts.
In the 1970s he used fat Albert's
as his thesis statements,
explaining all the ways you use
the cartoon to educate children.
He goes to all of this on his resume
for creating educational content for TV,
which helped him land to gigs on
future shows like picture pages,
the electric company,
and more deep down.
Bill calls me it not want to continue
making children's contents and he was
really only doing it for the paycheck.
He took a break from TV to come out with
comedy albums and they did extremely
well. He wants six grammy awards and he
was suddenly thrust into the limelight as
being one of the best standup comedians.
He would pride himself in writing clean
comedy that anyone could listen to and
he would often criticize other black
comedians like Eddie Murphy for using
obscenities
when he was 47 years old.
Bill Cosby start as a character named
Dr Cliff Huxtable in the Cosby Shire.
The Huxtables had five kids just like
bill Cosby and Israel wife Camille.
People assumed that this story was
parallel to who he was in real life.
It became so popular.
The TV ratings showed that half of
the country was tuning in to watch.
At that time back,
people were almost exclusively portrayed
negativity in the media America witness
criminal activity and controversial
protests from the black community.
This was the first show to portray and
the upper middle class black family,
both parents,
they were funny intelligence and
hardworking people who had an education.
A black American was finally being
seen in a positive light and it was so
genuinely funny.
Even white people were watching.
It helps to bring society together and
help them understands that really we're
all the same. Unbeknownst to the audience,
none of this was ever bill calls.
These idea the show was created by two
television producers named Marcy Casi and
Tom Water.
They wanted to come up with a concept
for a sitcom that no one had ever done
before and often seeing
bill Cosby stands up.
They approached him about doing a series.
Bill Cosby insisted that he would not
work for less than a million dollars a
year and the show needed to
have his name in the title.
He wanted to make this
TV show all about him,
even though the producers already knew
what they wanted to do with the series.
Bill Cosby tried to control the narrative.
He pitched the idea that the show should
be about a taxi driver who was tasked
with taking care of the kids.
He wants it to be married to a Latino
woman and he feels he would be funny if
she worked a traditionally male
role like a carpenter or a plumber.
He chose a taxi driver for his character
because he wants it to be able to go on
monologues for the majority of episodes
in order to tell the jokes that he
normally tells in his stand up routines.
The produces pushed it back with Cosby
explaining that original vision for
portraying the new black American family.
They eventually convinced him to give it,
to try and it exploded into a
cultural phenomena. However,
Bill Cosby received all of the praise
and recognition for all of the positive
changes that it made in society.
The show was filmed in New York City and
it attracted a lot of emerging African
American talent. People love to build
calls these character of cliff Huxtable,
and most people believe that he was
just playing an exaggerated version of
himself.
He was giving black people acting jobs
when they had never had the opportunity
to work in the industry before.
Is anything more than a
background character or an extra,
he would have a parade of women who had
come to audition to be on the Cosby show.
People who worked with him knew that
he was constantly cheating on his wife.
They assumed that these
relationships were consensual.
Ego would be seen speaking to Cosby.
She would get one or two lines on the
show and then she was never seen again,
but no one could have imagined how dark
the situation with bill Cosby actually
was and the doors were closed
and a lot of ways the Cosby show,
Trudy did revolutionize the industry
and no matter who he wants as a person,
there is no denying that. He was also the
first African American to win an Emmy,
but for fans of the show,
he was America's Dat.
People idolized him and he knew it.
He wasn't afraid to take advantage of
people's trust and their respect to the
absolute fullest extent, even though the
vast majority of the show was fiction.
There were moments when bill
Cosby incorporated stories
from his real life into
the Cosby show. For example, there was
his relationship with his son, Ennis,
who was the parallel to
the character of Theo.
He grew up getting bad grades in school
and bill Cosby constantly called a son
Lazy and told him that he
wasn't trying hard enough.
It was like to reveal the
Ennis actually had dyslexia.
Once he was given a tutor to help
him cope with his disability,
he began to do much better in school and
went on to attend Columbia University
teacher's college hoping to become
a special education teacher.
Bill Cosby told the writers
of the show what it happens.
They used a parallel storyline
with the character of Theo,
the characters playing Cosby's children.
They all grew up and the show ended in
1992 in 1997 and this was on vacation in
Los Angeles, driving a Mercedes. His car.
He got a flat tire so he pulled over to
the side of the road in order to fix it
in a completely free active violence.
A young white man who was high on drugs
attempted to rob [inaudible] and it's
reached for his wallet, but the man shot
him in the head. When the Pavarotti,
you showed off her bill Cosby's house
asking for a comment about the death of
his, I mean the son, he quietly said
he was my hero and shut the door
often taking some time off to grieve.
Bill Cosby returned to show business.
He tried and failed to stop
more TV series as well.
He came back in the public eye
after his famous Jello commercials.
He was having financial trouble in the
shows were no longer doing well in the
ratings behind the scenes of the Jello
commercial c scolded parents and kicks
children off the set.
If they were not behaving well enough,
he would get into arguments with
business executives about how to sell the
product because he thought
he knew better than them.
He would often add lib instead
of following the actual
lines that had been given.
This body being so difficult to work with,
he was ending $3 million a
year doing just these ads.
Bill Cosby realized that the
image of a perfect father,
it was working and people loved it,
so he decided that he wanted the world
to believe that he truly was this great
person.
He gave college scholarships to African
American students and participated in
multiple charities and his name.
However they,
his true colors would come out on set
and whenever we went on lecture tours,
he spoke down to African Americans under
the guise of giving people tough love.
If his words were spoken
by a white person,
they would be considered
disgustingly racist.
He was always very degrading talking down
to other black people as if he was on
this pedestal of some
sort of moral high ground.
One of the most famous examples of
this is known as the poundcake speech.
During this speech given at the NAA CP
on the 50th anniversary of Brown and
board of education bellicose.
We blamed the black parents for their
children's poor behavior and he wants
something 20 minute rants and lecturing
and talking down to African Americans
who were living in poverty.
He said that if it were not for
their laziness and irresponsibility,
then wise people would have more
respect for African Americans. He said,
we are not Africans.
Those people are not Africans.
They didn't know a damned thing about
Africa with names. Nick Shinika,
Shelia Guar Muhammad's and all that
crap and all of them are in jail.
It was so bad that in the transcripts,
the NACP how to add their own commentary
in parenthesis off to some of Cosby's
worst comments just so that people would
know that they disagree with a lot of
what he said.
Some people agreed with bill Cosby.
Ben's applauded him of the
schools in a race traitor.
In 2005 a sociologist and professor from
the University of Pennsylvania named
Michael Eric Dyson wrote an
entire book in response called,
is bill Cosby right? Or has the
black middle class lost its mind.
Dyson breaks down points,
budding points,
just how wrong bill Cosby is
and how truly difficult it is.
African Americans do overcome racial bus,
white privileged and
socioeconomic disadvantages.
It was never a secret that bill
Cosby was cheating on his wife.
He was often gold,
a womanizer and openly admitted in
multiple lens of years that he had
girlfriends outside of his marriage
once in Ebony magazine. He said,
when you turn 40 you look at the enjoyment
you may get from a given activity and
then you look at the amount of work that
may have to go into it. For example,
sex with a young,
beautiful women who has plenty of energy.
A talented young actress named Lily
Bernard was mentoring under bill Cosby and
the hopes that she could
get to pot on the show.
She was zoned that he was taking
the time to teach her about acting.
He always told her that she was one of
his kids and she truly did see him as a
fellow, that she never has any intentions
of sleeping with him and believed that
everything was strictly professional.
She became friends with the other actors
on set and everyone believed that she
would eventually become a
new character on the show.
When Cosby thought she was ready,
she finally got the part in the TV show,
which was a speaking role that's
only lasted for a few seconds,
often knowing her for a year,
Bill Cosby convinced her to go to Atlantic
city with the promise that she would
meet an agent who was going to
help with her acting career.
She had no reason not
to trust him after all,
she felt like bill Cosby was a dat when
the golf that he gave her a drink and
she blacked out. She woke up to him raping
her on the floor. It was so surreal.
She couldn't believe it was happening.
She was in denial hoping that it
was just a bad dream. My name was,
I have Rhianna's. He see Sanken. She
told him that she would go to the police.
He threatened to sue half a defamation
and told her that she would go to,
he also threatened to completely ruin
her acting career. He's holds, Huh?
You're dead to me. Bernard.
You hemi. Your debt.
Lydia Bernard's was no longer allowed
on the side of the Cosby show.
Not only did she lose a
mentor and father figure,
but she also lost all of her friends
that she got to see every day.
The events was beyond traumatizing far.
She attempted to get a role
in a few other TV shows,
but eventually gave up on acting and
decided to become an artist even years
after the rape Lily Bernard's was afraid
to come forward because she truly did
believe that he would make good on
the promise to sue her for defamation.
She was a struggling actress in New York.
You could not pay our rents and
let her learn, hire a lawyer.
She also knew that if the idea of
bill Cosby meant so much to her,
it would also crush the hopes and dreams
of African Americans across the country.
She also knew that no one would
believe her. Now is important.
We added this was just one of many stories
and we couldn't possibly go over all
of them in the short video and social
of 60 women came forward with similar
stories about bill Cosby.
Andrea comes down to is the first woman
to come forward and publicly accused him
of rape. They offered to
pay for her college degree,
but she brought him to court instead.
Several journalists wrote about the case,
but many people brushed it
off as a false accusation.
People said that comes down to is just
trying to make money from bill Cosby him
that he couldn't possibly be anything but
this perfect cliff Huxtable guide that
the kids over up with displaying to all
of the proof being out that the issue
was not reignited.
Again until 2014 a standup comedian named
Hannibal Buress was gaining a lot of
attention for his role in the
comedy central series, broad city.
During one of his standup shows,
he called out.
Bill calls me saying that he had no right
to lecture black people on their bad
behavior when he himself is a rapist.
The story went viral.
Suddenly people knew and they actually
listened because it was another black man
confirming the truth.
Soon to she went public.
13 women approached Andrea constant to
say that they'd also been victims of rape
by bill Cosby. Soon after the comments
by Hannibal Buress when viral,
a reporter from the Associated
Press attempted to ask
him about the accusations.
During this interview,
we can see firsthand towel.
Bill Cosby uses intimidation to make the
reporter back down from revealing his
comments on the rape accusations.
He tells the reporter that if he
wants to have a serious Korea,
he will not show the questions.
In that film.
He was seen as so powerful
that he was untouchable.
The spice. All of these accusations
coming forward in the media.
People truly could not fathom that bill
Cosby was a rapist. Many of his friends,
they came forward to defend them,
including Whoopi Goldberg.
She later recanted her statement.
The first trial had a hung jury.
They could not decide
if he was guilty or nos.
Prowls a supposed to be unbiased and
jurors and not supposed to learn too much
about a defendant outside
of the court room,
but decades of seen cliff Huxtable
on the Cosby show on TV men's.
It was nearly impossible for people
to separate the tune of matter.
How hard they try it.
They just couldn't believe that this sweet
man capable of such a horrible thing.
Bill Cosby admitted
more than once that yes,
he gave quite alludes to women
in order to have sex with them,
but he didn't define that as rape.
He had actually admitted this
in interviews with magazines.
He is before all this,
I don't have to hearing him say this
so casually on the witness stand.
The jurors knew that he was truly guilty.
Even though 60 women have come forward,
only three brought their claims to court.
Keep in mind that this doesn't
mean the rest of the line.
It just means that they want to move on
with their lives and not have to retell
the stories of the worst moments in their
life and have that personal and family
lives exposed in the media.
In September of 2018 he was convicted
of aggravated indecent assault and was
sentenced to three to 10 years in prison.
At 81 years olds.
It's very likely that he will spend
the rest of his life behind bars,
so I already have you found that
video. Interesting. If you did,
please do give us a thumbs up below.
Don't forget to subscribe.
Got a suggestion for us.
Leave it in the comments below and
if you see when you like upvote it,
the ones that come to the top,
I'm most likely to see one thing
about making some of those.
So go ahead and do that.
Also,
if you're looking for something
else to watch right now,
I've got another channel.
Cool. Today I found out.
You'll find that link to on the screen
now as well as below this video,
and as always,
thank you for watching.